Anyone's pissed off with politics at the moment.
Try It yourself back.
If you're gonna look at politics from any time back in history,
it's always been hell.
It's always been rubbish.
It's always been all over the place.
Yeah.
And uh,
I think um,
transparency as opposed to opacity,
if that's the word.
You know,
the more transparent things are,
the more you can check,
hey that guy's lying about that.
You know,
if we could work out what's the lion,
what's another lie?
That would be really nice.
I didn't know if we could have lights at detected on all the time.
Do I think it's going to be mine?
Reading mind reading?
Well I really think that we're going to have technology within the next 50 years
that allows people to definitively understand whether or not someone's being
honest.
That would,
it would make it,
um,
I,
I'm sure someone could get a bad side of that,
but it's shoring up front.
You think there's a lot of good stuff on that.
Yeah.
Someone could say this is going to happen though.
I want this to happen.
A lot of people,
scams are going to fall apart.
What do you call them?
Ponzi schemes.
Pyramid schemes.
Yeah.
A lot of that.
It's going to fall apart.
Why they called Ponzi schemes?
Ponzi?
Yeah,
I think so.
I think you can.
There's like a,
there's a bunch of those little terms like fit gazey.
Jeff Ponzi,
I think for Gazy is one that people use for fake.
It was a,
there was a limousine company that was writing bad checks for gazy limousine
service and it became like a thing on the east coast where,
Oh,
this guy is a,
he's a fucking lazy cop.
Let means you're a fake cop.
Yeah.
Wow.
For gays,
he became a big word.
Charles Policy.
Then Jeff Palsy,
dirt bag.
Look at him either.
He's happy.
He's 20 he's about to leave.
I put over there.
Gentleman walking.
Go roaring twenties just wrapping paper.
Love.
Do we tell people as you're listening,
please look up Charles Ponzi on Wikipedia and
yeah,
so that's it.
And how did he die?
Did they explode?
Hopefully get hit by a meteor.
It'd be nice.